[Musique]
l'une des premières en france la ville
de rouen a essayé de répondre à la
question comment peut-on être piéton
soudain privé de son moteur de son
volant le site a d'abord la surprise de
découvrir à pied une ville qu'il avait
oublié la sienne dans la rue de la
grosse horloge et dans la rue
saint-romain désormais interdite aux
voitures et aménagé pour les piétons on
profite du calme de la sécurité et
surtout d'un quartier historique que
l'automobiliste ne regardait plus
mais au delà des vieilles pierres et de
l'esthétique
il y a le commerce l'une des plus fortes
densités commercial que l'on puisse
trouver dans une rue on ne cherchera pas
dans la zone piétonne de rouen où le
promeneur l'emportent sur le client mais
à paris rue mouffetard depuis de longues
années c'est rue mouffetard est
interdite à la circulation pendant les
heures de marche et la foule des piétons
s'y pressent tous les matins mais le
mobilier urbain n'a pas été modifié il
ya toujours une chaussée des trottoirs
il n'existe pas de grands parkings
proches de la rue et comme les riverains
et les camions de livraisons restent
autorisés à circuler
tout devient très compliqué et s'il y
avait des parkings c'est payant n'est
pas
puisque vous commerçants de la rue vous
seriez partisans d'une interdiction pure
et simple total de toutes les voitures
dans la rue si oui à la possibilité de
laisser son véhicule quelque part mais
assez proche parce que vous connaissez
de clients ils se déplacent pas au delà
de 100 m c'est trop pour lui gide pour
eux pour une rue qui interdit de la
circulation il ya beaucoup de camions
bus et mieux la rue est très large pour
interdire le stationnement et c'est
comme ça tous les jours le jour tous les
jours que voulez vous faut bien que les
gens regardent mais magento que les
endroits venir à pied parce que tu étais
absent touristique c'est tout
et puis ça serait beaucoup plus
facilement beaucoup de commerçants
pensent que
le commerce périclitera ils ont fait une
expérience
vers 16h20 des prix peut s'attendre à
des heures oui ben ça donnait quelque
chose de concluant
le siège on est là on est content qu'il
va chez moi il va chez moi c'est un
client de l'hôtel
s'il rentrera moi je vais au
commissariat vous venez avec moi j'en ai
eu marre de tout votre corps in amenas
non non non non ne pourra pas non plus
pourquoi parce qu'il n'a pas encore s'il
doit rentrer hier le préfet de police il
a dit vous avez tort monsieur nous fais
un travail énorme travail qui n'auraient
pas le droit d'empêcher des clients nous
rendait dans l'hôtel mêmes enfin
l'aspect non
vous laissez pas passer mettez la barre
des 70 commerçants sont contre et 300
tours et ça vous gêne beaucoup dans
votre coin bien sûr que ça gêne les
clients avec leurs valises quand même
pas passer jusqu'à l'hôtel on les bloque
ici et s'il y avait un parking par
exemple s'il y avait des parts qu'il n'y
aurait pas pu y aurait pas de problème
mais ya pas de parking pour les rues
piétonnes tour reposent toujours sur le
même problème la grande misère du
stationnement parisien nos clients ne
peuvent pas entrer dans cette rue ils
viennent à pied et habitent loin très
souvent ce sont des gens de province des
genres de l'étranger ou d'autres
quartiers de paris de grande banlieue
et ces gens l'interdiction formelle
d'entrer dans notre quartier ce qui fait
qu'il ne il n'achète plus rien de chez
vous c'est à dire qu'ils ne viennent pas
ils ne viennent pas ils ne viennent plus
et les nouveaux on les connaîtra pas
dire a pas de nouveaux clients ne
travaillerons peut-être avec l'ancienne
clientèle
si ces gens acceptent de se mélanger
avec cette faune de hirsute du quartier
saint michel
mais ces gens n'aiment pas beaucoup
marcher avec eux ce n'est plus une rue
piétonne ces tueries couper la
circulation une rue piétonne je comprend
une piétonne rend ce que les gens
peuvent accéder qui est des parkings
auto complice sur les télécentres comme
dans des pays étrangers
mais là c'est une rue complètement
coupée de la circulation cette
expérience qui pourrait être bénéfique à
tout le monde et donc accueilli comme
une brimade et un ghetto en conclusion
la rue piétonne sera avec parking ou ne
sera pas
[Musique]